la grande maison de savannah
au xviiie siècle l'économie de
plantation nécessite le recours massif
aux esclaves
craignant la propagation de maladies en
provenance de madagascar ou d'afrique
les administrateurs de la colonie font
construire des lieux de quarantaine
celui de saint paul se trouve à part
qu'à jacques cartier isolée au nord de
l'étang cette quarantaine destiné aux
personnes libres ou esclaves qui se
trouveront à bord des bateaux affecté de
maladies contagieuses est installé dans
un imposant édifice connu sous le nom de
grandes missions tourner vers le nord la
façade principale dispose d'une double
galerie aujourd'hui fermé côté temps le
rez-de-chaussée est en pierre de bazas
de tailler et l'état jean - l'ont
recouvert d'un enduit à la chaux
au 19e siècle le lézard et devient la
maison d'habitation du grand domaine
sucrier de savannah en 1935 la grande
maison change à nouveau de destination
elle est transformée en entrepôt pour le
sucre toutes les fenêtres sont alors
muret et les planchers et des plafonds
supprimés
abandonner définitivement depuis le
milieu des années 1960 la grande maison
de savannah témoigne de l'histoire de
l'exclavage dans l'île
présentant de grandes similitudes
architectural avec cet ancien lazare et
l'autre hôpital érigé par la colonie à
la fin du xviiie siècle à saint pol
abrite aujourd'hui les bureaux de
l'établissement public de santé mentale
de la réunion